[Music]
[Applause]
how's it going bros my name is Pierre
anyway welcome back to garage
I don't even uh her name is heat oh yes
I remember the name for a first time who
smoke in here I don't appreciate it and
we're on out of batteries I shouldn't
waste my time cuz time is valuable
there's time you just wait where did I
come from I think it's here
I should go here right here oh yeah
you're right about that you're damn
right about that alright so there's this
crazy girl around here who breaks the
electricity and stuff and we needed a
her would you just be quiet I know the
code cuz I'm the security God if I don't
know call that I'm gonna be stairs a
piss off authorized personnel how am I
not authorized pissing me off that's
stupid
that's damn stupid what it's okay it's
okay I'm not pissed
I'm not pissed I was thinking news day
before and their custom story was bug
then it kind of bugged me out see what I
did there I didn't kiss please tell me
I saw one way we can go walk here that I
didn't exactly shake out or whatever
stupid paintings I see making um we're
running out of battery stairs so it's
that stupid thing I thought it was a cat
baby or whatever it is so we're gonna go
here actually oh there's nothing here
well that's good I'm glad because now
we're nowhere I'm screwed I'm gonna die
well let's get there's nothing not even
the worn-out Wow and the sound is back
that's not good for anyone okay
it got on so no then all right let me
just turn off the wall in saliva it's
really frustrating
all right mm-hmm so yeah we're gonna die
I've always really liked about to die
but it still is
he's moving as slow as always here oh
yeah so crazy
what come on here yeah not just that
here's something okay that sound good
thank good at all Oh ours door did we go
in here
nuns bed bedroom really okay let's see
if we can make it in time I doubt it
come on here you all you got to do is
place around on that doorknob and you'll
all be over
actually if she just wait pillow
air baby in here so we should go ahead
all right it works we can go out of
men's room bedroom bedroom why don't you
say that all right now
and one air I need to find [ __ ] Oh
God we're gonna die
alright this is sound so bad let's see
my bad
oh we're dying yeah what's going on oh
no no no no just in the bathroom and pee
your bats yep
lock the door but if luck okay yeah why
look my knots oh god those feet aimed oh
now is this phone again
[Applause]
all right we got oh we got this we have
this it's no problem he's not gonna come
in here over again she just wanted to
wash your hands it's cool the good thing
is we're gonna die anyway so what's that
sound dude
oh no not again are we good
but we're actually gonna die now so see
if we can make it out no we're out of
batteries oh no it's like kitty cat
hey kitty cat when are we gonna die we
never die give you skin - oh there we go
oh no oh we know what's gonna happen
no jelly oh [ __ ]
[Music]
hello everywhere now
I hate that hey dad pick up slow and
steady to gouge but hang out I keep
retrying is but I don't want to retry
and do loads safe state I guess alright
we're back here but I don't know like
there's no batteries anyway I am
obviously missing some important
batteries let's go back in the bathroom
and there's some [ __ ] again and see if
you can find batteries there that's my
bash can understand why shouldn't I
ignore it all the doors on the way
probably sometimes you have to use the
doors too wait wait a minute
not we're gonna go here actually it's
okay I mean it's good time I like it
thanks I don't like it exit wow that's
great we should go there this is gonna
be a mess frame for the cleanup I mean
he's not the cleaning lady but he's
responsible for it
doodling it reminds me of a what's that
[ __ ] game called fear you know what a
girl is like hey I'm gonna ride on you
all and shed pretty much this kind of
dead space tuition too I don't I don't
even know anymore
that thing is so [ __ ] creepy Wow
anyone here why sir wind makes no sense
alright we couldn't go here
that's stupid [ __ ] kid
damn that butt though hi Josie can we go
left no I just need a battery come on be
reasonable what is this why can't we
walk in a period where I don't
understand
well yeah yeah we couldn't holy [ __ ]
I saw it I saw the a don't [ __ ] fool
around there there we go alright well we
see what's on the other side so it can't
be like why do we have to do that
alright whatever
Oh God [ __ ] sound uh-huh alright
buddy
it's you and me oh wow that sounds
killing me can't wait
nice pulse bro she's like hey welcome to
my party how are you how are you I'm
naked I'm good yeah so I was gonna
happen with that thing I can
goddess mannequins and anything about
the mannequins god damn it
all batteries good that doesn't look
very huh okay
all right you just have to move and I'm
just gonna take these I hope it's
batteries I said collectable item or
[ __ ] pin memo we find one god damn it Oh
Oh No
huh okay we got this beer man Oh
jinx grounded really oh okay so I'm
having nine but we're seriously need
batteries where are all the [ __ ]
batteries Oh God
anyone in here please let there be a
[ __ ] battery
[Music]
alright come on buddy
hey welcome back on trip my party
welcome welcome here mostly and welcome
to G skies I'm just on it oh god they're
all naked wait wasn't I eaten here a
second ago
I really don't understand us I don't
understand what's going on I'm gonna die
again
I wonder if I can like no I need to
collect the pin too but it's a sucker oh
man I'm gonna die again Oh boxes no I'm
not I don't even want to watch come on
oh there we go thank you
[Music]
slow and steady girls and that's exactly
how you pretty quick yeah quite
definitely anyway that's it for today
bro I'm sorry and then go over well but
I'll be back I'll always be back like
favorite if you enjoyed and I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
oh I knew that no [ __ ]